What are you?
(jazzy Christmasy music)
I am ready to get into the holiday spirit.
I fucking love Christmas.
Christmas is the holiday that I can
pull out all the stops
like I've been waiting
all year to make this dish right here,
and it come out tasting
like mwah, beautiful.
My body is ready, my soul is ready,
I wanna like put Christmas lights
everywhere and scream to the world.
We're so ready.
Yeah.
(laughing)
(jazzy Christmasy music)
This is so pretty I don't
know even wanna eat it.
The best part about it is it's so pretty.
This looks like a weird Christmas cookie
version of a chicken pot pie.
It's a gift from Santa.
Huh.
Dang, that's hard.
This is what I always wanted
Christmas to taste like.
This is like 80% raisin and 20% snot.
This kinda tastes like I just took a bite
out of like a piece of Chapstik.
It tastes like a giant mound of
the inside of a fig newton.
(jazzy Christmasy music)
Is it a booze cake, I
hope it's a booze cake.
Oh no, now this is rum cake.
Feels like it's soaked in something.
Just like, are these gummy bears?
I'm eating rum.
But I'm okay with it.
I think it just tastes like
sweet, which is amazing.
It's like a dream.
Good stuff, man, no
happy hour for me today.
(jazzy Christmasy music)
Ooh, this looks like a pierogi.
What's a pierogi?
It kinda smells like a
chicken pot pie on the inside.
It's full of potatoes covered in cheese.
I'm cool with that.
Oh my God.
Way. This's amazing.
I futz with this.
I'm gonna eat this whole thing.
I would eat this on Christmas.
I would eat this every day.
(jazzy Christmasy music)
Whoa, this is pretty.
It's beautiful.
It looks fancy, but it also looks
like I'm not gonna like that.
It just looks like
scarier on the way down.
It looks like fish to me.
Oh it's so squishy.
Sounds disgusting.
(laughing)
Ooh, I should not have smelled it.
I don't don't have a problem with this.
Huhm.
Ugh, Uh-uh (negative), nope.
(jazzy Christmasy music)
It is fried chicken.
Oooh, yeah!
Oh my God, oh my God, I know what this is.
In Japan, they eat like fried
chicken and Christmas cake.
Is that like really a thing in Japan
like KFC is the "Oh,
Christmas, we get KFC"?
I would love to have KFC for Christmas.
There's no way I was expecting KFC
when I came in here today.
I think it was a Christmas miracle.
Oh, this is Christmas.
Cake, booze, and fried
chicken on Christmas.
That's amazing.
What do we do in America?
Right?
I feel like everything
looked pretty Christmasy.
But some of the things just
were not what I expected.
It was definitely surprising to see things
that like I recognize and have had before
but would never associate with Christmas.
The Japanese get it.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean I could do that like once a month.
No cooking, just call KFC,
call the Colonial, he's got you.
(laughing)
I haven't had KFC in a long time.
It's actually better than I remember.
(jazzy Christmasy music)